ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata siamo arrivati
a febbraio è una delle cose che più
parla secondo me di carnevale i generali
questo periodo sono le frappe
chiacchiere e vabbè fatemi sapere come
le chiamate perché hanno sempre nomi
diversi a seconda dei colmi di nuovi
quale però la svolta che voglio offrire
a tutti quanti voi che oggi si faremo
delle frappe chiacchiere quale però il
piccolo twist di oggi che si faremo
delle breve per carnevale ma le faremo
al microonde in tre minuti velocissime
per fare l'esperienza microfono scarica
l'abbiamo inibito adesso avrà una
vescica come segue
[Musica]
chef mario dicevo avremo bisogno di
farina zucchero blatter 10 ne che
abbiamo qui dei secoli lievito vanillina
burro un uovo dell'olio zucchero a velo
per spolverare un pochino e della grappa
da bere per dimenticare
partiamo subito col procedimento ma
prima indossiamo il mio meraviglioso
grembiule
prima di tutto vorrei ringraziare a
tutto microonde puntonet che ha ispirato
diciamo questa ricetta
quindi se grazie a tutto microonde punto
nette che altro dire
speriamo che funzioni zucchero e un
luogo 75 grammi di zucchero aggiungiamo
l'uomo ea rimini la gola che raccoglie
in un angolo o premi il casinò sopra
peso al volo in un piattino mai dato un
buffo pro graziano marco grazie mario
per la tua umiltà
vediamo 50 g di burro nel frattempo e
buttiamo lì nel microonde per 45 secondi
[Musica]
50 grammi di latte sembriamo 5 50 grammi
di roba mammamia vanillina mezza bustina
di lievito per dolci per accecare affari
mezza bustina con l'unico metodo logico
st buccia di limone grattugiato che è
stato cartuccia da ogni con quel giorno
di inter e le superfici che rimangono
history moreno e rimane tutto acqua e
alcolico iniziamo ad aggiungere la
farina
ma scusa ma male breve sono coliche alle
chiameremo sbornie 400 grammi leperino
bastico e adesso aggiungiamo che il
piano 400 g di farina che mi sembrano lo
spazio certo noi nel planetario no alle
nonne e soprattutto quanto con l'amore
succede sempre succede sempre succede se
la farina un bisogno di carla diviso non
so cosa fare in questo momento sono nel
panico
no guglielmo tocca l'impasto è strano
nomi non mi torna sotto molti punti di
vista sacro con orari più nello sprecare
qua dicono di avvolgerlo cieli di
metterla dentro e avvolgerlo con un
panno un mio io c'ho tempo queste cose
ragazzi del panno umido c'è qualcuno
affetto cai che uno deve limitare a un
aspetto aveva finito di impastare
mettiamo dentro sei troppo elastico
perché forse non hai evitato uno molto
dieci minuti da valori fila matti molto
noto
beh
questo ente ha chiaro né come è stato un
omaggio a tutte le persone che conosco
non sono veramente preciso ragazzi
scusate
ok senza noi sta montando danno si possa
usare
ok forse abbiamo avuto dei problemi di
auto e possiamo dirlo no forse senza
forse abbiamo avuto dei problemi di
audio
chiediamo scusa quando le cose sembrano
andar bene c'è sempre un modo in cui la
vita
renzi sono momenti difficoltà ci si sono
scaricate le batterie quindi purtroppo
per questo video di carnevale a rendere
omaggio a scherzà aprile partito le
principi lentamente la moto non si vede
meno dell'album e ronde non tu sei pazzo
ragazza fumando qualcosa che succede è
qualcosa e neroli se qualcosa sta
bruciando e queste sono le nostre
che dire l'aspetto è abominevole
e quello di un figlio che non avrei
punto l'odore è quello di un figlio che
ha voluto il prezzo si sia commestibile
saper quello dei bambini non è male
sono mortificato mi chiedo scusa per
rubato minuti preziosi alla nostra vita
a tutto microonde non speri cosa ho
sbagliato esattamente le dosi montato
anni montato bianco messo al burro
sciolto le salari linate più la
vanillina e ce l'ho messa comunque la
grappa successo e questo è quello che ha
ancora mammamia sembrano quasi sono
belle da vedere a chernobyl un chewing
gum cessi tipo vabbè ho capito passa
basta va bene e noi che non fa bene ma
bensì come faccia bene questo commento
basta avete stancato mette ragazzi ci
vediamo ci vediamo alla prossima
settimana
ciao